so you mentioned part of Xbox
uh Microsoft bought but that's then and
as nmax for 7.5
billion dollars
well what's it like joining the Xbox
team you've you've um I think written
about it what's what what are the what
are the exciting aspects of that
you know
when your company goes through a change
like that no matter what it is even if
it's somebody that you've worked with
for a long time you never know what
you're in for you hope
um and I had worked with them uh for
since we started doing console stuffs
with Morrowind was you know they came to
us came to me and hey you should make
this game for the Xbox and so when they
were making that console
um had a great experience with them
and then on the 360 with Oblivion and so
I guess the point is
we felt that we had a very good
relationship with everybody there
and we understood uh what their culture
was but you never really know
and and I mean this honestly it's been
awesome that the culture inside of
Microsoft and Xbox that that people see
from the outside is the culture inside
the way they talk about players
the um the way they'll invest in the
players the risks they'll take
the thoughtfulness from Phil Spencer on
down has been you know feel really
really lucky
and then a game like Starfield where
look we've had a lot of success with
with the games that you talked about but
we've never been kind of the
platform seller
you know the game
for a platform for a period of time and
so you know there is a lot of pressure
there's a lot of responsibility there to
make sure we deliver for everybody
is there a chance that Starfield is
exclusive to Xbox it is it is exclusive
it's officially right yep yes
so you're
I get it so extra pressure also creating
a new world
yeah it's new but keep in mind for us
that exclusivity is not unique even
though we've done PlayStation stuff and
I think the PlayStation 5 just an insane
machine they've done a great job and
we've had great success on PlayStation
we were traditionally a PC developers in
the beginning
we transition to Xbox became our lead
platform like morrowind's basically
exclusive to Xbox Oblivion was exclusive
to Xbox for a long period of time Skyrim
DLC was so we've done a lot of like our
initial stuff is all Xbox so
we get into development and saying we're
focused on Xbox and it's not abnormal
for us in any way it's been kind of the
norm
and from a development side I you know I
like the ability to focus so our ability
to focus and say and have help from them
you know the top engineers at Xbox to
say we are going to make this look
incredible
on the new systems is like from from my
standpoint it's just awesome